[Music]
okay is that too big of a slice no hey
guys it's me jasmine and today i'm gonna
be challenged to recreate a vacation
through food i've been receiving letters
from people who've had to cancel their
vacations because of kovid so i am going
to help them live out their vacation
through an authentic recipe given to me
by a local so they can at least go on a
tastebud trip the first postcard comes
from tiffany who had to cancel her trip
to greece dear jasmine i was supposed to
go to greece this summer for a wedding i
was really looking forward to eating all
the authentic greek food my body could
handle and i absolutely love desserts
can you show me how to make an authentic
greek dessert yes i can greek cuisine
often uses oregano dill
mint bay leaves and a few others but i
want tiffany to have the most authentic
taste bud trip possible so i am
enlisting the help of greek local madam
ginger who knows the ins and outs of
greek cuisine hey jasmine madame ginger
here and i'm really really happy to help
so everyone thinks that in greece we
only eat sublaki or muzaka yes we do eat
those and we really love them but every
local would know how special and
traditional orange philo pie is in
greece we call it porto callocta that's
why today i'm giving you my recipe for
this delicious greek dessert you really
really need to try it i've never made
orange pie before i've never even heard
of it and i think i've got my work cut
out for me today let's do this so one of
the star ingredients in this cake is
phyllo dough so using our hands we're
just going to rip our field dough into
uneven pieces but it's going to be
important that we separate the layers
because we don't want them to dry in
chunks it could be as uneven as you like
because we're going to crush them up
anyway so no big deal i do this when
it's still frozen so it's easier to work
with once it starts to defrost you can
get some extra moisture in there which
makes it harder to work with you just
want to fluff them up because you don't
want them to stick together make sure to
aerate them pretty nicely and don't
forget to separate the layers this is
kind of therapeutic i am quite enjoying
this so once you've stripped them into
these uneven pieces go ahead and aerate
them again and spread them out evenly
onto the pan once you have something
that looks like this we're gonna bake
them in the oven for about 20 minutes
until they're lightly toasted and
hardened so the next step is to whip the
eggs and sugar together until they're
light colored and fluffy i feel like
recipes are sometimes so specific yet
oddly so vague like what does light
colors mean what does fluffy mean is
that soft or is that thick i'm not
really sure so we're going to give kelly
a call kelly is our wonderful culinary
developer on tasty and she's going to
give us a quick egg whipping 101. hey
kelly hi jasmine i need some help okay i
was wondering if you could give us a
quick egg whipping 101 i am looking at
the recipe and it says to whip the eggs
until they're light and fluffy what does
that mean are there do's and don'ts what
should i be looking for first off are
your eggs room temperature yes okay
perfect what you want to do is put your
eggs and sugar in a bowl and whip them
with a hand mixer or stand mixer over a
medium high speed until they've like
doubled or tripled in volume their color
will change from like a darker yellow to
a pale yellow color and they'll be thick
like not like a mayonnaise but maybe
like in between a sour cream and a
mayonnaise consistency don't over whip
it because then you can't go back and
also you'll know it's done when you pick
up your whisk and some of it falls down
and if it sits on top of the other
batter in the bowl and creates ribbons
that's when you know it looks perfect
okay got it thank you so much you're a
lifesaver you're welcome i can't wait to
see the finished product bye
now that we've gotten our lesson from
kelly i feel pretty prepared got our
room temp eggs here gonna add them all
in and now we're gonna whip them until
they're light and fluffy so after about
five minutes of mixing we now have these
gorgeous ribbons that don't sink in
immediately and now we're gonna add in
our sunflower oil baking powder vanilla
extract so for the zest you only want
this outer layer of the orange the white
spongy part in the middle over here that
is called the pip and that's very bitter
so if you start zesting the pith and
including it in the cake you might get
some bitterness to it so the zest we're
adding in is from unwaxed oranges and
what unwaxed oranges means is organic
and then we're gonna add in our full fat
greek yogurt
i'm gonna mix this in a little bit
before we use our mixer again to mix it
up until it's nice and smooth we're
gonna grab our phyllo dough that we
dehydrated earlier and we're just gonna
crush it up into small pieces
and then fold it into our mixture i am
taking my greased baking dish and i'm
just going to
add it in there
oh my god it smells like butter orange
and vanilla oh my goodness i'm so
excited to try this i'm just gonna
spread it so that it's nice and even in
the baking dish
heavenly i'm so excited to put this in
my body
okay into the oven it goes so while the
orange pie is baking in the oven let's
go ahead and make our syrup we're just
going to add in our orange juice
squeezed our water juice from one lemon
an orange peel and our sugar let's give
that a good stir
and we're just gonna let this simmer for
about 10 or 12 minutes until the sugar
dissolves and the syrup thickens the
orange pie is finished so we're gonna
poke these holes into the pie so that it
can absorb the syrup when we pour it in
afterwards so after you've poked your
holes into the orange pie we're gonna
slowly ladle our syrup over the cake
until it slowly and fully absorbs all of
it i've let the pie cool for about an
hour still warm and that's why i want to
cut it now because i do still want it
when it's nice and fresh you can see
that it already absorbed all the syrup
okay is that too big of a slice no oh my
gosh it looks so moist sorry if you hate
that word
look at that oh my goodness let's try it
cheers
that might be one of my most favorite
things i've ever made that is so good
the zest that we added makes the pie
taste so fresh the phyllo dough inside
is so good it's almost custardy and you
can actually feel the phyllo dough
inside and it adds different layers
within the pie to create a different
texture this is so good tiffany you're
gonna be so happy
okay guys we have taken our taste buds
all the way to greece today with this
delicious porto callopita i really hope
i said that right make sure to take a
picture and tag me on instagram when you
make this and if you love traveling
through food as much as i do make sure
to head over to bring me and check out
our latest series where we unbox
surprise country themed snack boxes see
ya oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you